so we're going to go and find some
liquid nitrogen now breaking we keep it
in a really large jeweler tank at the
back of the shop so we're going to go
find that now so this is a jeweler that
we use to keep the liquid nitrogen in
within the building so it's much more
convenient for us and our students to
get it so what we're going to do now is
we're going to fill up our small Dewar
to carry the nitrogen back to the lab so
you can probably hear it hissing and
fizzing going into the bottle and you
can see all the nitrogen evaporating off
nitrogen exists as a gas molecules of n2
and it is interesting because the bond
between the two nitrogen atoms is the
strongest bond that you can get between
any two atoms in the periodic table any
two atoms that are the same sometimes if
you have two atoms that different the
bond can be slightly stronger but the NN
triple bond is one of the strongest that
you can have but what we're doing is
we're filling up the Dewar with liquid
nitrogen so that we can take that back
to our lab to do our next experiment so
many explosive compounds things that
you've heard of like TNT and other
explosives all contain nitrogen which
are isolated atoms and when the
explosion goes off the atoms come
together and release energy nitrogen is
used widely in laboratories partly
because it is not as reactive as oxygen
so if you do an experiment and an
atmosphere of nitrogen you can avoid
reactions that might be occur with air
you can also use nitrogen when it's
liquefied as a coolant liquid liquid
nitrogen boils at minus 196 degrees
centigrade 77 degrees absolute and you
can just hold it in a normal thermos
flask so this is a doer of liquid
nitrogen and you can see that the
nitrogen is evaporating from the top
coming out and frosty coming down over
the sides because it's a little bit more
dense than the air you can see it's
heavily laden with ice and you can see
that the ice crystals are starting to
grow on the top of the top of the Dewar
here very cold though you know so you
mustn't touch it for too long
so if we just like tip some out on the
floor we can see that the nitrogen
itself will come out like a liquid you
see it's like a pouring water but the
interesting thing is water when I pour
it on the floor it forms like a puddle
and it does nothing useful in fact it
sort of gets in the way the liquid
nitrogen when I pour it on the floor
it forms these really quite nice bubbles
and they like fly across to the side of
the room and take all the dust with it
pretty cool but if you put materials
like rubber or flowers into liquid
nitrogen instead of being soft and bendy
they become really rigid and you can
smash them with a hammer
so you can see all of the bubbles
forming on the steel tray now and
they're sweeping away over the dust
quite nicely as they evaporate and move
further afield
so Neil's got a piece of tubing and it's
really quite a flexible tube and you can
see it's really floppy and now he's
going to put it into the cryogenic
liquid nitrogen and freeze it and see
what happens to the to the M to the
rubber but you see another interesting
thing there is that the the could
nitrogen is siphoning out through the
tube and that's a really good joke
because you can direct that siphon that
someone's trans alike and freeze their
legs so I think that's enough Neil let's
see if it's a bit harder whoa that's
shad and there's quite a nice little
operation that I've heard about in which
you can take the lens out of somebody's
eye when they're suitably Anita tais and
this lens and can be frozen and then put
on the lathe and you can change its
shape so you get the right shape and
then you let it unfreeze it goes soft
again and you pop it back into their eye